when I used to work at Friday's in a
restaurant that endless appetizer that
was my worst enemy as a surfer oh my god
Mama's never tip you it's five dollars
they're gonna tip you Ave up I'm not
skipping nobody if my dinner is only
five dollars that's just me keeping it
honey take one hey what's up GG lip
where Y bein Corday and these are my
essentials so first up is my toiletry
bag first of all is this Israel this is
this is the toilet this is what a real
toiletry bag looks like when you're on
the road or in general told my deodorant
a toothbrush you know it's just super
convenient because I was just walking
around with all my [ __ ] man loose so my
mom was like you need to tell the tree
bag and so I got myself this jump so it
cuz it's so convenient African leather I
can't pronounce this French word but
this is awesome my Cologne not even my
Cologne but it's my Cologne you know I'm
saying like I always wear this [ __ ] you
smell your boy guaranteed it's the
African leather euro or whatever sound
the cheetah makes this cheetah looks
deadly right he'll go ass up I'd do it
on the wrist do that make sure my hands
smelling good this what you do it come
on rub it on your hands on the wrist put
it on you like his lotion you know I'm
sitting having a part of your embodiment
you know it kind of reminds me of the
Ron Burgundy cologne y'all remember that
[ __ ] from weatherman one we had the
cheetah right like this yeah yeah yeah
yeah from anchorman
I keep a composition book with me at all
the time to write Rhymes to write down
ideas write down my thoughts you know
this why I don't ever forget any idea so
this is a brand spanking new one my old
one is at the crib that Joan that I wish
I would have brought that down one got
all the real money but this one is
fairly new and it got like different
versions of the lost boy tracklist you
know what I'm saying like I was trying
to figure out the tracklist got all
different versions of it uh you know
production credits you know all type of
dope stuff that's in here got like maybe
[ __ ] like 40 of these at home just
stacked up you know I'm saying just uh
in the archive the keepsake it's gonna
be in a museum one day hopefully you
know what I'm saying so uh you always
keep a rhyme book on me with some dope
[ __ ] these are beats by dre headphones
the studio versions I always I'm gonna
roll these is my hater blockers the
soundtrack to my life it's played
through these headphones always write a
lot of my music when I'm on the road
this is it right there were you and that
bus with ten other people
never I record a song I'll listen to it
and these headphones if a mix is truly
like dope it's gonna smack in headphones
and air pods in the car The Lost Boy
bother this kid named YB in court I
don't know if you ever heard of him he's
decent from what I heard um okay so I
always keep a chest bag of some sort on
me at all times so I'll put it on 350
sent out this jump to a lesser extent
you know is this is very clutching
convenient when you going through
airports
we got the Lost Boy bags that's coming
out right now for this bout to hit the
streets it's gonna go crazy and I just
always keep some clutch and convenience
in here like uh got my throat coat
always keep hella these with me because
you know I'm always on the road always
touring so it's a lot of vocal strain on
my voice so I just been trying to take
better care of my voice you know what
I'm saying so I always put this in some
hot water and some honey and be good
keep your voice straight because this is
my instrument you know what I'm saying
and I've just got to make sure my
instrument is always fine-tuned it's
always a good shape it just helps that
my mom told me I should get it she
recommended it so yeah a lot of these
essentials shout out to my dukes
ah yes my passport I like random
designer accessories you know like a
passport like a Javon Qi passport holder
you know I'm saying just random
accessories it's pretty cool and uh yeah
man I got a couple stamps in this job
you know it's real that's the one of the
many blessings of music you know being
able to travel the world trying to make
sure this whole [ __ ] is filled by the
time it expires which is like 2028 but I
got my wallet right here which is
awesome
my life's a mess right now you know but
it is what it is uh got some some pounds
in here you know I got flex Ani
got some euros I think this Swiss
dollars it's all in here then I have a
bunch of old money and this is from what
I used to work at Friday's in a
restaurant I always like collect like
the old bills you know it's like this
old five dollar bill and I keep this in
my wallet you know where mommy to never
go back and always like be grateful you
know for where I am in life because it's
at times a weekend tend to like a little
sight of our blessings you know I'm
saying so I keep these old fives till
you know just remind myself for that you
know you just keep pushing
you know the Lost Boys sneaks you know
I'm saying The Lost Boy is out now so
these are some awesome John's that's
about to hit the streets you know I have
a an endorsement deal with a with Puma
of the youth brand ambassador so we came
together and we got these these are
customs but we're about to make these
like hit the streets very soon you know
saying got the Lost Boys sign right here
got the other part of the the project
right here they're very comfortable that
is it's easy to match these you know
what a simple outfit so shout out the
Pullman shout out so the artist who
created these I have the most like lazy
10 essential [ __ ] ever I just pulled out
[ __ ] I have but I feel like that's what
it's for you know
see just laptop right here ain't gonna
show you how what I was watching like
now I'm joking this is what I was
watching last night for your mother cuz
that whole who think I'm talking on some
other [ __ ] y'all crazy as hell but uh
yeah this is my laptop is this clutch's
[ __ ] like I got uh I just got a bunch of
cool [ __ ] on here you know I got DJ
Serato Pro pro tools that way I'm able
to like look at all my sessions and you
know just have a say in the mixes or
just like edit some [ __ ] that I want to
edit here catch always keep a hoodie on
me at all times never know when it's
gonna rain you never know when it's
gonna get a little cold at night so you
always got to keep a hoodie and I always
keep like an earth tone hoodie because
it always goes with your outfit no
matter what you have on especially this
one Lost Boy hoodie you know I'm saying
it's this available right now if y'all
want them fashion is definitely
important and it's like peanut butter
and jelly where hip-hop music you know
what I'm saying so it's a part of you
part of yourself as a person
all right GQ now that was my ten
essentials which possibly may have been
the worst or the best how you look at it
in GQ is ten essential history
[Music]